Amazing guys. Welcome to the call. All three of you. I don't care if there's one of you. I don't care if there's zero of you because there's going to be a replay guys. I'm going to talk about when to go for the kill and by the kill. I mean the clothes.
This is a question that came up. This is a question we cover in the training.
For sure, at least once probably have covered it more more than once, but it's something that I do want to just reiterate because it's important. So today I was at the gym.
I saw one of our students, Mr. Vance Rowley, who is somebody I've known for a long time, actually went to school with him, know his whole family, the whole thing, and he just recently joined. He's been looking for something new.
He just barely sold one of his old business and has been kind of peeking at stuff for a while and finally decided to join. And he has hooked a business owner, got rid of that business owner, hooked another business owner, given them three leads.
And then we were just at the gym today in between sets kind of talking about like when to go for the deal. And he didn't even ask. He knew the answer, but I just kind of made sure to remind him of these facts.
So what I want to talk about today is when is the right time to go for the kill? When is the right time to go for the close? So some of this stuff is going to be stuff that you already know.
Some of this stuff is going to be maybe some stuff that you don't know and some stuff that I've just kind of discovered over the years after doing this hundreds of times.
Now, the first thing I want to cover is how many leads do we actually send to the business owner? Well, there's a couple of rules because there's no exact number of leads because each individual situation is different.
Each business owner is some business owners are more ready than others, some are less ready than others. However, there are some certain rules that I personally follow.
And again, guys, I've closed a lot of deals in my day and I have I have a very, very high close percentage because quite frankly, I only get on deals that I can close and that's just how I roll.
I go and find the ones that are closeable and then I get on them and I close them.
Okay, so rule number one with the number of leads. I never, ever, ever, ever send more than five leads. Now I remember Eugene Song.
He's an old dog in the game. By the way, Stephanie Prather, how are you? Happy Friday. Congrats on your deal.
Once again, I know you got it a week or so ago, a week or two ago. Eugene Song was a prime example.
He was in another program. He knew me from there. And I remember we jumped on a call.
I was called. I called him on the way to Vegas. I just remember this for some reason right before Christmas.
And he said, dude, I'm like, I've been sending people leads like crazy. It's like I sent Alaska like two weeks worth of leads.
I said, well, you're doing it wrong. You're sending way too many leads.
Guys, anything that you give away, if you give it away in too much abundance, it loses its sizzle.
It gets it. The newness, the magic of it is gone. Right.
Anything that you give away too much, it's too available, is no longer magic.
So I was like, you're giving away too many leads. Guys, I never give away more than five leads.
Never, ever, ever, ever give away more than five leads. Okay.
Second rule. You do not have to wait for a business owner to close a deal in order for you to go for the close and to close a deal.
They do not have to close one of your leads for you to get the deal. Does it help? Yes. Does it help tremendously? Yes.
Can you control it? No. You do not have to wait for a business owner to close one of your leads to go for the deal.
Okay. A step further than that, you don't even have to wait for the business owner to actually give the estimates before you go for the deal and you can get the deal.
I would say that's a bit more advanced. I would probably wait until the business owner has run the estimates.
But there was a time back in late 2021 when we were cooking and moving at such velocity and we had so much momentum that I remember we would send, we would call, we'd send two leads.
And if I felt in my gut, this person's ready, I was scheduling the Zoom call and I was closing it.
They would call the business, they would call the homeowner, they would schedule the appointment, but they would not even get to the house and I would close the deal.
Okay. You do not have to wait for them to close a deal. You do not even have to wait for them to actually give an estimate.
I would recommend if you've not gotten a deal or you're not getting a few deals, let them get the estimates, but you do not have to wait for a deal to close.
Next rule, if they close a deal at any point on lead number one, number two, number three, number four, go for the kill.
As soon as you, if you send one lead and they close it, it's time to go.
Time to go. One is good. If the first one they close, it's done. Go for it. They've seen enough, they've tasted enough.
It is time to go for the deal. Those are my three rules. Okay. No more than five.
You don't have to wait for them to close a deal and as soon as and if slash as soon as they do close a deal, it's game time.
Those are my three real rules. Now, on top of that, I want you guys to understand that this is, this is an art.
This is something that you're going to have to feel and understand within your gut.
You're going to get this. You're going to do this enough times that you're going to kind of get sensitive to win and pick up these cues of when people are actually ready to go.
And they're going to start asking buying questions and they're going to start talking in a way that lets you know that they are excited and they're going to start.
They're almost going to start moving themselves through the process without you even having to do it.
And those are the people you got to catch them, man. You got to catch them before it gets late.
So I was telling Vance today at the gym, I said, dude, he was trying to get this deal locked up before Wednesday or before Thanksgiving.
He tried to schedule the zoom. And so I was following up. I had it go. He's like, dude, they went out of town. So no problem. It happens.
But I said, remember, every day that passes from here on out, the chances of you closing that deal becomes worse and worse and worse because they are hot.
He told me some of the things they've said. He said that it's a husband and wife. The wife was like super excited and brand new.
She was saying that they can handle a bunch of leads. And she was really responsive and all this stuff.
I was like, this person's ready to rip. They've said he said three leads. I said, dude, it's time to go. Time to close this deal.
Every minute you wait from now on, you're losing. It's a lower chance of you getting the deal.
So there is a time. There is a point where it becomes you're waiting too long.
And it kind of reminds me when I grew up on my farm, my dad's farm, we would raise this crop.
This is called alfalfa. It's the hay that we would sell it to these dairies in California, to these milk cows.
And the plant itself, you would grow it and grow it and grow it and grow it.
And then when it was ready, it started to turn purple. This little purple bud would come off on the leaf.
And as soon as it became purple, every day that passed, it became less and less valuable.
It started to get rank. It started to become not as it's like it reached a certain point where it was max.
And then you wanted to wait to get as close as possible to that point where it started to turn purple.
And then every day after that, you're losing money because the quality of the hay is not going to test as well.
It's not going to be as good. It's not going to sell for as much per ton, et cetera.
I view it the same way. We're raising, it's like a crop, right?
We're sending the leads. We're calling. We're kind of like nourishing them all the way up.
And then there's a point when it's time to freaking cut the hay. It's time to go and make the hay.
It's time to go. It's time to get the deal. And every second you wait, you're losing opportunity.
This happened to me when I started this program three years ago, literally three years ago.
I was looking, if you guys saw my post earlier, go comment on it if you don't mind.
I did my first live video in this group, November 30th, 2021, three years ago, three years ago.
It was not the best time of year. It was a time where if you were to look at the entire year, it was not necessarily the best time of year.
You could have chose the spring where it's easier to get leads. You could have chose whatever.
It's not holidays. When it's holidays, people aren't thinking about buying programs, whatever.
According to all the experts, it was the wrong time of year.
But I realized that I had raised this crop. I had raised this Facebook group.
And there was an opportunity to go and harvest at that very moment.
And if I waited every day that I waited, it was going to become less and less.
And that's when I made the decision. I'm just going to go for it. I'm just going to go.
It's the exact same thing with each one of these deals. And it's interesting because each one is different.
I've sent one lead that they didn't even get the deal.
They maybe ran one lead and I've gone for the close because they start asking buying questions and they just felt right.
And I closed it. I've also sent five leads. They've closed two of them.
And I've lost the deal because I think I waited too long or I skipped a step, whatever.
But what I want to just remind everyone on this call is that there is a time to go for the kill.
And when it comes, you need to move everything aside and you need to go for it.
I don't care if you need to move a vacation around. Go listen to my video.
The one I took the screenshot, go to the files, go or go to the media, go to video, scroll to the very bottom.
Go and find the live. The very first live ever did is back on November 30th, 2021.
OK, and I forgot about this. Guys, when I ran this live, you can you can see that it was last second.
It was it was like I was trying every reason to run this, to start this group.
I was trying to push it off. But I couldn't. I just knew I had to do it.
And you listen on this live. I forgot about this, but I actually was supposed to go to Disneyland with my family, my my kids and my wife and everything.
And I ran the call. I told my wife, I said, I'm going to run the call.
This is the day before Thanksgiving. I announced it. I said, I'm going to run it on Monday.
I'm going to have to meet you down there. I know you guys are leaving on Sunday or you're leaving on Monday morning, but this has to happen now.
And I'm sorry. And I will. I booked the flight and everything.
I said, as soon as I get done, I am going to rush to the airport. I'm going to meet you in Disneyland.
OK, that was the plan. And I got on the call. I ran the call and there was a bunch of questions and I did not.
I didn't close it fast enough. I completely like was I was so into the call, answer the questions and pump.
And I got done and I jumped. I had my bag probably knowing me. I didn't even have it ready.
Got my bag out of the car, started zipping down to Vegas and realized I missed the flight.
And so I ended up stopping, getting sushi, sitting by myself at a sushi place, a sushi bar and just enjoying got a hotel, did some work and came back.
OK, so again, guys, there's a time to go for the kill and there's a time when it passes.
And when you feel it, it's time to strike. They say it's time to strike, strike when the iron's hot.
OK, and some of you guys are sitting on deals right now and you're like, well, I should just say and one of my brothers, Zach, if he's on here, if he watches this, he's like the king of procrastinating the best time.
And I get it, dude, because you want to wait for that perfect time and that perfect time.
It's like, well, let me get him one more lead. And sometimes we genuinely think that and sometimes we're just procrastinating because we're scared.
But sometimes that one lead that you're waiting for, that one extra lead, you're going to lose the deal.
We've done this before. We've done this as a team, my team.
We've done this with people that are supposed to join this program.
And it's like, well, such and such thing.
And they're not going to be by their computer.
And it's like we push it off and push it off.
Then all of a sudden something happens like, yeah, I just got hit with the tax bill or something happened to my dad and I got to go be with him in another country.
And it's like, dude, we should just run the deal.
We should just run the call. Right.
Anyway, this kind of ties into my whole philosophy of send it when you feel it.
And even if it doesn't make total sense, just realize it's all going to work out because you're going to win more than you're going to lose if you just go for it when you feel like the time is right.
So, guys, I'm so pumped about this group.
I'm stoked.
I'm really, really stoked.
I hate even talking too much about 3.0 because then everyone's like, when is it going to come out?
I don't know the date because I want to make it so good that it doesn't even it's unrecognizable.
So I'm not even going to give you guys an estimate, but I'm going to try to get this thing done before the end of Q1.
I know that's like seems a bit far out, but I just want you guys to know we are completely redoing the way that we're doing everything.
Now, for those of you like, I'm going to wait.
No, start now, dude.
I from this right here, we have Ryan Dalton's made eighty seven thousand dollars a month.
You can go make thousands, tens of thousands.
You can become a millionaire with what we have right now.
But I want to make it that much better.
I want to make it so unrecognizable that doesn't compare to anything in the marketplace.
And it's it's it's going to be so much different.
Right.
Not right. You guys have no idea, but I am super, super stoked about that.
And also, I said this in my I think it was in my post two days ago that I realize when I first started this group, I was I was going live.
I was dropping nuggets.
I was doing all this stuff and I've kind of gotten away from that a little bit just because of scale and bandwidth.
But I'm going to make it a point, even if it cuts into my other stuff, that I am very, very active in this group.
You guys see me a lot.
I don't know if it's going to be every day, but it's going to be multiple times a week, whether it's a post, whether it's alive, whether it's a little replay.
But I'm super, super, super excited.
Not about the new people that are going to join this, but about you guys, about those of you that have put your trust in me, that have that have committed to being here.
And I'm going to take you guys to the freaking promised land.
OK, so I appreciate you guys being on here.
And Stephanie Prather says continued time is our enemy.
That is very, very true.
That said, guys, go enjoy your weekend for those of us that are going to be doing a little hustle, hustle, get up early.
The best thing, let me end with this, the freaking best way to start a weekend.
It's not by getting in an ice bath or whatever.
That's great.
That's cool.
However, the best way to start your weekend is schedule a sales call at six thirty a.m., seven a.m.
on Saturday morning and go and bang a deal in a stripe and have the most phenomenal two days of your freaking life.
You want to talk about dopamine.
You know, you know, when they talk about Richard or Andrew Huberman talks about you get an ice bath to get a dopamine dope.
That's cool. Cool.
No pun intended.
You want to know what the ultimate dopamine hit is?
Go get a deal at six thirty a.m.
on a Saturday morning before you go to the gym, before you eat breakfast, before you even see your kids and see how that sucker carries you through the Saturday and through the Sunday.
That used to be my freaking mantra.
Saturday morning, six thirty slinging a deal.
And then I'm going to have the most amazing day of my life.
That's what I used to do.
I'll get back to it.
I'm out. We'll talk soon.